Angela Merkel's announcement in October came
as a surprise.
Europe's longest-serving elected leader may
achieve what no modern day chancellor has
managed before: a controlled exit from politics.
I won't run again as party leader at the next
CDU party conference in Hamburg.
This fourth term is my last as chancellor
of Germany."
Merkel became the first woman at the top of
the CDU in the year 2000.
Surprising nearly everyone the newcomer from
the East led her party's break with its political
idol Helmut Kohl over a party funding scandal
-- even though Kohl was her mentor.
The determination and power instinct the party
SAW there -- was also what it would GET over
the 18 years.
Those who refused to accept that the CDU was
no longer a Gentlemens' club, soon learned
the hard way: one by one, her competitors
had to go.
After becoming Chancellor in 2005, Merkel
took her CDU party on a political journey,
many criticized as a shift to the left -- shedding
conservative benchmark policies like military
conscription and performing a U-turn on nuclear
energy over the Fukushima desaster in Japan.
By then her role as party leader and her perception
as chancellor had long became inseperable.
Merkel's political brand as the one who guarantees
stability was born.
In the midst of the Greek debt crisis she
defended risking Bbillions of German tax payers
money by claiming there was no alternative.
There is no alternative to supporting Greece
to secure the financial stability of the Euro.
Die zu beschließenden Griechenlandhilfen
sind alternativlos, um die Finanzstabilität
der Eurozone zu sichern.
Her "no alternative" reasoning also saw her
keeping Germany's borders open during what
became known as the migration crisis in 2015
-- THE political challenge that still defines
her leadership of her party and Germany as
a whole.
If we were to now doubt that can do this -- considering
our European responsibility, our humanitarian
responsibility and our responsibility for
Germany -- then we wouldn't be the Christian
Democratic Union of Germany.
But we are, and that's why we can can do this.
Merkel herself was long seen as conservative
party leader "without an alternative" that
could replace her.
The fact there are now several credible candidates
is also fuelling speculation over how much
longer she can
remain chancellor.